- Hello everyone. Thanks for joining us.
My name is Kaveh Khoshnood.
I'm a faculty at the Yale
School of Public Health.
I'm the faculty director for
Humanitarian Research Lab
at our School of Public Health,
and I've had the pleasure of
knowing Professor Claire Greene
long time ago when she was a student,
an MPH student at our
School of Public Health.
Professor Claire Greene
is an assistant professor
in the program on forced
migration and health
at Columbia University Mailman
School of Public Health.
She received her PhD in psychiatric
and substance use epidemiology from
Johns Hopkins Bloomberg
School of Public Health.
And as I said,
she got her MPH from our
School of Public Health
in the Chronic Disease EPI
and Global Health Department,
and she did her postdoctoral training in
implementation science and
humanitarian health from Columbia.
At Columbia she teaches
courses under collection,
analysis and use of data to
improve humanitarian assistance
and on mental health and forced migration.
Her research focuses on designing
and evaluating strategies
for improving the effectiveness
and implementation
of mental health and
substance use intervention
in humanitarian settings.
In addition to her research and teaching,
she regularly consults for human agencies
and humanitarian NGOs on
the design and evaluation
of mental health and
substance abuse program.
Thank you so much, Claire, for joining us.
I'll pass it on to you.
- Okay, thank you.
Thanks everyone who's here
and thanks to those online.
It's truly a pleasure and
honor to be here today.
So as Kaveh mentioned, it feels
very good to be back here.
So I did my MPH here at Yale
and I have so many wonderful
memories of my time here,
one of them being a photo,
it's at the top left of your screen.
I did my thesis research
under the supervision of
Professor Trace Kirsha and
through the Downs Fellowship,
which was led at the time by Kaveh.
In China, focused on mental health
and substance use and HIV.
And the photo just below the,
on the bottom left-hand side of the screen
is actually my MPH thesis
poster presentation,
which my parents were so proud of that
they actually framed it
and it's been hanging in their basement
for over 10 years now.
So I guess I owe a big thank you to Yale
for helping me make my parents proud.
But in all seriousness,
it's really a pleasure to be
back here. Such fond memories.
And really, Yale was where I discovered
the fields of humanitarian health
and mental health and their intersection.
I worked with the postdoc
at the McMillan Center
on a review trying to understand
the alignment of mental
health interventions
that are implemented in practice
and those that are researched
and perhaps unsurprisingly,
the evidence we have
does not align very well
or didn't align very well
with those interventions
that are actually implemented in practice.
And for me,
this is really what sparked my
interest and motivated me to
move along this trajectory
in mental health
and humanitarian settings,
which is one that I'm still
motivated and excited by today.
So a big thanks to Yale and to all of you.
All right, so I thought I'd start
just by talking about
why we should care about
mental health in the context
of humanitarian settings.
Kaveh and I were just talking
about how there's such a
plethora of health needs in
these contexts, but for me,
I think there are a few reasons
why mental health should
definitely be an essential part
of humanitarian assistance.
The first is just
thinking about the burden.
So the best estimates we have suggest that
22% of people in conflict
affected settings
have a mental disorder
that's more than three times
higher than the general population.
We know that even beyond that,
people in humanitarian settings
experience elevated distress
and that affects their
functioning and their wellbeing.
So there's a lot of people
affected and who could benefit
from mental health and
psychosocial supports.
We also know that people in
humanitarian contexts have very
limited access to services.
There are not a lot of specialists,
not a lot of mental health providers,
fewer than 10% of people in
humanitarian settings with a
mental health problem, access services.
We also know that outside of
the formal services system,
a lot of the community and
informal supports and protective
practices are disrupted in
emergencies and when people are
displaced as well,
which further increases the
risk of mental health issues.
So I thought it would be helpful
to provide a little bit of
a historical context here
because I think it highlights
where the field has been going
and and where we are now and
where we need to be going in the future.
So it really wasn't until the
late 1980s that humanitarian
actors first convened, at least on record,
to discuss mental health needs
in the humanitarian context.
And this happened in a
refugee camp in Thailand with
refugees from Cambodia,
where according to these
humanitarian actors,
they noticed a deteriorating
social condition that needed to
be addressed within this context.
Move forward one decade,
and we have the first evidence
of psychosocial interventions
being applied in a humanitarian
setting in the context of
the conflict in the Balkans.
And then it wasn't until 2007
to 2009 that we started to get
guidelines and really formalized
recommendations around how
to respond to the mental health
and psychosocial needs in
humanitarian settings.
The publication of the
inter-agency standing committee
guidelines on mental health
and psychosocial support.
We also saw that during this time,
UNHCR added mental health conditions
to their list of kind of,
or the list of conditions they capture
as part of the health information system.
Prior to 2009,
there was essentially no record
of people seeking support
for mental health through
the primary care system.
And then in the 2010s,
we started getting information
and guidelines around how to
integrate mental health
psychosocial support,
which I'll start referring
to as MHPSS because it's a
mouthful across different sectors
in protection services and
primary care in other settings.
So since 2010, there's really also been
this proliferation in research on
mental health or MHPSS
as you can see here to the right.
These are the publications
in PubMed that include
mental health and humanitarian settings.
And you see this rapid increase
after about 2010 in the
amount of research being
conducted on this topic.
In parallel, we've also
seen the development of
various resources to support
the implementation of
MHPSS in emergencies.
WHO has invested a lot
in developing these scalable
psychological interventions,
which are manualized interventions,
evidence-based interventions
that can be delivered by
non-specialists in order to
address that gap I mentioned
between access to specialized
mental health providers
in these contexts.
And I think the good news
here is that we have effective
mental health interventions.
This forest plot on the upper
right hand side of the screen
is the result of,
or are the results from an
umbrella review or a systematic
review of reviews where
they've essentially found that
in humanitarian settings,
we have pretty good
interventions that seem to work,
particularly in adults to
address issues like depressive
symptoms, anxiety symptoms,
post-traumatic stress
symptoms and distress.
There's also been a lot of
investment in implementation
science and trying to understand
how can we overcome some of
the barriers that are exist
to delivering and accessing
mental health and psychosocial
support in emergencies.
So all of this is very good,
but one of the things that
I've been thinking a lot about
and that I think motivates some
of the work I'll share with
you today is why haven't we
seen this evidence really being
translated into population level impact?
Why is it not being adopted
within the humanitarian sector?
And I think there are a few
reasons why we haven't yet seen
kind of the translation of
this evidence into improvements
in population level wellbeing.
The first is that many of
the interventions we have,
there are effects are short-lived.
So often we see that people,
when they're in say a,
group-based intervention over eight weeks,
they tend to improve, but after
then it intervention ends.
They often return toward, maybe not fully,
but regress a bit as far as
their mental health conditions.
We also know that evidence-based
interventions are often not
adopted or sustained
within routine services.
So a lot of the evidence is
generated within the context of
research and it's challenging
for various reasons to
actually integrate that into
routine care delivery systems.
And then the third point here,
which I think is really
central to my talk today,
is that many of these interventions
really do not consider
the contextual, structural,
or social determinants of mental health,
which we know are so important to people's
lived experience and wellbeing.
So this is why I present
to you what I think is the
rationale for multi-sectoral
interventions.
And what I mean by that is, first,
we know that mental
health is a central part
of people's lived experience.
We also know that it
exists within the context
of many other factors.
And these are just a list
of of social and structural
determinants of health and mental health
that we see in the literature,
but also from some of our
formative work that relate to the
mental health and wellbeing
forcibly displaced persons.
But if we think about mental health as,
as operating in a vacuum by
itself and ignore these root
causes and these risk factors
for mental health problems,
how would we expect perhaps
that the intervention effects
that we're trying to to
to test can be sustained?
So we did a survey with 225
refugee and migrant women in
Ecuador and Panama trying to understand
what are the factors of
your lived experience
that relate most strongly to your
overall wellbeing and life satisfaction?
And what we essentially found
was that people's sense of
safety and their standard
of living were most strongly
correlated with their overall
wellbeing and quality of life.
This probably isn't so
surprising for many people,
but what I think is important
to note is that these are not
usually the focus of our mental health
and psychosocial interventions.
Often our interventions are
focused very much on our
thoughts and our feelings, our behaviors,
our interpersonal relationships,
but if really at the root of
people's wellbeing is their
sense of safety and protection
and their standard of living,
are we missing the mark by
thinking kind of too narrowly
around what's happening immediately
in people's minds and in
their kind of immediate
circles and relationships,
not to undermine or or discount those,
there are important a aspects
of of people's wellbeing,
but I think what I'd
like to argue today is
we need to think a bit more broadly.
And so part of that is
highlighted in this figure here.
So if people,
if we are able to address
people's mental health with these
interventions that I've
shown you that are effective,
that people are operating and
returning to context where all
of these risk factors
continue to be present,
can we really expect
that those mental health
effects will be long lasting?
So I'd like to start today
just with an example of a study
that we did a while ago now
that looked at this intersection
of intimate partner violence
and mental health in Nyarugusu
refugee camp in Tanzania.
So Nyarugusu is a refugee camp
in western Tanzania that was
established in the mid 1990s.
At the time we started the study in 2014,
there were 65,000 registered
refugees living in the camp,
primarily from the Eastern DRC.
And just a little bit of context here,
refugees who are living in
Nyarugusu do have really a lot of
restrictions as far as their mobility.
They're not allowed to leave the camp,
they also are not able to work.
There are a lot of restrictions
that can't get formal employment.
A lot of their livelihood opportunities
are really restricted.
And I think that's important
context when we think about
their risk for both intimate
partner violence and also also
mental health conditions.
And we'll see how that
plays out in just a minute.
So within this context,
intimate partner violence
or IPV is one of the main
protection priority priorities recognized
by UNHCR in Nyarugusu.
It's well kind of that it's
a prevalent public health
condition affecting many of
the people in this setting.
We also know based on
data from the camp itself,
but also some more kind
of rigorous data from
population-based surveys,
surveys in the eastern DRC
where most of the refugees are
from that IPV is one of the
leading risk factors for poor
mental health among women
of reproductive age.
So here's some data from
this household based
population-based survey
that was conducted in
the Eastern DRC that
shows essentially that
women with a history of IPV have roughly
a twofold increase likelihood
of having depression,
PTSD and suicidal ideation
or lifetime attempts.
We don't see the same pattern
for substance use, however,
I think it's pretty consistent
across a lot of these other
common mental disorders to
see that there's an increased
risk here associated with IPV.
So within Nyarugusu,
the approach to addressing
these related conditions
is pretty siloed.
So on the one hand we
have the protection actors
and at the time it was the
International Rescue Committee
managing a lot of gender-based
violence prevention and
response programs to address IPV.
And then we also had some
health actors focused on
addressing the mental health
and psychosocial support needs
through the Tanzania Red Cross.
These services were
separated at multiple levels,
so they were largely siloed
and not very well coordinated.
And so essentially what this
means is if say there's a
survivor of IPV with mental
health needs and she goes to
the Red Cross to get mental health care,
those services are often
not very well coordinated to
address the GBV or IPV needs as well.
So our goal with this study
was to see can we test an
integrated intervention that
simultaneously aims to address
intimate partner violence
and mental health in order to
improve kind of the
synergies between these two
multi-sectoral approaches?
We started off this study by
doing some formative research
to understand what are the
salient mental health and
psychosocial problems affecting survivors
of IPV in Nyarugusu.
And we use two methods. We
use free listing interviews,
which are a rapid qualitative method,
often used to identify a list
of concepts and prioritize a
list of concepts or
problems in a community,
followed by some in-depth came
format interviews to better
kind of flesh out and describe
the priority mental health
problems that we identified
as affecting IPV survivors in
this context.
So the results of this formative
research process revealed
really three key mental health
and psychosocial problems.
The first was stress or too many thoughts.
In Swahili it's msongo wa mawazo.
Which was really described as those
internalized feelings of distress.
And then we had this concept
of huzuni or deep sadness,
which was more of this
externalized presentation of
distress. So feeling really
angry or aggressive or upset.
And the third mental health
problem that people described as
affecting survivors of
IPV was fear or hofu,
which was characterized by worry,
trembling or fearing that something bad
was going to happen again.
And so these data were really
helpful for us because we were
thinking within the context
of an integrated intervention,
perhaps the mental health
component can focus on these three
priority mental health conditions.
The other part of our formative
research and a really key
aspect of this multi-sectorial
process was thinking about
where to position this type
of multi-sectoral intervention
within the refugee camp setting.
And we went through a
process of community mapping,
which first involved
like physically mapping,
who are the stakeholders
involved in these two activities
and MHPSS support and GBV
response and where are they
physically located in the camp,
which is the map on the left hand side.
And then we also went through
a process of doing some focus
groups with people in the
community, with community leaders,
with humanitarian practitioners
to understand how people
navigate these different
systems and and services and
that are available to them.
And what I think is really interesting,
what was super helpful and
critical about this process for
us, as you can see on the
right hand side in blue,
are those kind of formal actors
or the formal system where
you have the protection providers
that do the GBV response
and and prevention programs like the IRC,
you have the police,
you have case managers,
legal services and health services.
But what we didn't discover
until we did those focus groups,
or even from talking after
talking with the humanitarian
actors, we didn't yet
know of this entirely,
this informal system.
And so essentially why
this is important is that
for IPV survivors,
it's expected and really only
culturally acceptable for that
problem initially to
be aimed to be resolved
within the family.
And so it's really looked down upon
and there's a lot of stigma
associated with going directly
to that formal system.
So most of the survivors of
IPV are still operating within
this informal system of
support through the family.
And only if the family's not
able to resolve the issue,
can they start engaging with neighbors,
with the local police
force, with village leaders,
et cetera, et cetera.
So for us,
why this was important is
that if we only thought about
reaching women within the
foremost system of care,
we would have missed a lot of
people who could potentially
benefit from an integrated mental health
and IPV intervention.
- But the fact that they go
first or try to resolve it
into the family,
isn't that you also
because of the availability
of the other more formal services or
more on a continuous basis?
Accessibility as well.
- It's a great point.
Yes, certainly.
I mean there the access
to services specifically
access to justice was really limited.
And so the use of these local
courts and village leaders was
really essential for that purpose.
The way it was described to us
primarily was related to the
stigma with actually seeking services
through the formal system.
There were social consequences
of doing that unless it was
kind of the permitted,
I'd say by some of these informal actors.
But certainly access and availability
is another challenge as well.
Thanks for that question.
So with that information,
we designed what we called
the Nguvu intervention,
and Nguvu is a Swahili
term for power or strength.
It was an eight session
intervention that combined cognitive
processing therapy,
which is a psychological
intervention designed for survivors
of trauma that fit nicely
with those problem areas
we identified in that in
the formative phase of the research.
And we combined cognitive
processing therapy,
which I should also mention
had been previously tested in
the eastern DRC.
So there was some already
cultural adaptation that was done
that we felt needed
appropriate intervention
for this context.
And we combined that
with advocacy counseling,
which is an intervention that
has some evidence for reducing
kind of the chronicity and
intensity of IPV among women
who've already experienced
some form of domestic violence.
As far as the implementation,
this photo's a picture of our research
and our intervention counselors,
so our research assistants
and intervention counselors in
Nyarugusu after one of our trainings.
So we used this task sharing
approach where we hired a team
of volunteers from the
community or incentive workers,
they were given a very small
incentive to work with the
International rescue committee to
do some community outreach
as part of the GBV response.
And we worked with this cadre
of women and trained them in
this intervention so that they
could provide it within these
community settings kind
of integrated within IRCs,
broader GBV program.
The intervention itself
involved one individual session
followed by seven group
sessions, and again,
we integrated it within
IRCs Women's Protection and
Empowerment program with the
intention of kind of fitting it
within an existing system of
care that women were already
comfortable participating in.
So the women's protection and
empowerment program was not
specific to GBV, it was a,
a service that was provided to women.
It was not a stigmatizing place
for women to go and if they
participated there,
they wouldn't necessarily be
identified as someone who was a
survivor of IPV,
which was a a key
protection concern for us.
And then finally,
going back to our discussion
around the informal versus
formal systems of care,
we ended up recruiting women
through community-based women's
groups so that we could reach a broader
number of women from community
settings instead of relying
just on those who were
accessing services through those
formal channels.
As far as our study design,
we conducted a cluster randomized
trial where we randomized
those women's groups from
which we recruited to receive
these in Nguvu intervention
or to receive IRCs usual kind
of care program for GBV survivors.
And we were specifically looking
to enroll adult Congolese
refugee women in Nyarugusu
who reported past year
experiences of IPV and moderate to severe
psychological distress.
The outcomes that we measured at baseline
and then one week after the intervention,
so that's about a 10 week period
was were anxiety symptoms,
depressive symptoms,
symptoms of post-traumatic
stress disorder,
and then the frequency of physical,
psychological or sexual IPV.
So just to characterize
this sample at baseline,
we ended up enrolling
311 women in the study.
They were about 33 years of age on average
had lived in Nyarugusu
for 17 years on average.
This is really a protracted
emergency setting.
A lot of our research team in fact
had been born within this camp.
A lot of people had lived
most of their lives there.
Two-thirds of the women in
our sample were married and
living with their current partner.
And as far as their mental health,
this profile is largely by
design because they were required
to have at least moderate symptoms
of distress in order to participate.
But you can see kind of pretty
similar levels of anxiety,
depressive and PTSD symptoms
that are between a moderate
amount and a lot of symptoms
over the past two weeks.
And what I think is really
troubling but important is just
looking at the profiles of IPV as well.
So the requirement for being
eligible for the study is that
they reported having experienced some form
of IPV within the past year.
But as you can see,
the majority of women who participated
reported had been experienced sexual,
physical and psychological
IPV within the past year.
And it was actually quite
rare that women reported not
having experienced sexual violence
perpetrated by an intimate partner.
As far as our outcome.
So here we conducted mixed
effects models to look at the
difference in change from
baseline to follow up between our
Nguvu condition and those who received
or were referred to usual care.
And what we ended up seeing this,
these are just effect sizes
to kind of visualize the the
changes over time.
We did see that women who
participated in the in Nguvu
intervention showed significantly
greater reductions in
depression, anxiety and PTSD symptoms.
We did not see any change or
any significant change as far
as IPV between the usual care
and the and Nguvu condition.
I did just wanna go on a brief
tangent about measurement of
mental health because I think
it is important and actually
one of the most surprising and
interesting findings for me
is part of this study.
So one of the things that I
mentioned from the beginning is
after having gone through that
formative research process,
we decided that those
three concepts of distress,
hofu, msongo wa mawazo, and huzuni
looked roughly like anxiety
depressive PTSD symptoms.
And so we perhaps naively
selected some research tools to
measure our outcomes that
corresponded to depression,
anxiety and PTSD.
And so what we did after the
fact is we wanted to say, okay,
let's look and see how
our data cluster together.
What are the factors,
the underlying mental health
conditions and how these
symptoms of mental health problems
correlate with one another.
So what I'm showing you on
this slide are the items.
So each of those words
corresponds to an item on one of
those measures, the gray items
corresponding to depression,
red for anxiety, purple for PTSD.
And if we did kind of looked
at the factor structure and if
these three conditions
were valid in this context,
what we'd expect to see is
that the depression items would
be more correlated or
clustered with one another.
Similarly with the anxiety
and with the PTSD items.
So we did an exploratory factor
analysis and what we ended
up finding was something more like this,
it's like random mixing of
symptoms across these three
conditions that no longer looked like
depression, anxiety and PTSD.
So at first we sat there
and were kind of stumped.
We didn't know what to make of this.
We tried to say it was just some
strange statistical issue, who knows.
But after spending some
time with this data,
what we ended up seeing is
that these problems almost
perfectly aligned with those
three initial concepts of
distress that were described
to us by the women we
interviewed in that formative process.
So for me, what I take away from this,
I mean we know that mental health
is really difficult to measure.
It's we don't have gold standards.
We know there's cultural
variation in how mental health
conditions present,
but I think the bigger piece
and the bigger picture here is
just the importance of
listening and trying to avoid
applying our perspective and
a worldview that's familiar to
us on the data that are presented.
Because I think perhaps
naively we had done that in the
situation and kind of forced
what we were hearing to fit
something that was familiar
when in fact I think we saw this
amazing triangulation of our
qualitative research and our
quantitative research telling
us something quite different.
All right, so back to the the
study and the relation with
multi-sectorial interventions.
I just shared with you the
main results from the study,
but if we pull back the
curtain a little bit,
as always it was a bit messier.
There were a lot of
implementation challenges.
We had a lot of issues
with staffing and kind of
coordination and organization
and all of these other factors
that come up in most research projects.
I hope or not I hope, but I bet.
And so we took some time to
conduct a process evaluation to
do some interviews with
different stakeholders who
participated in the study,
those who were a bit
external to the program,
some focus group discussions.
And then we also collaborated
with a group from
the Global Health Justice and
Governance program at Columbia
to do a funding analysis
and look at policy documents
at the same time the study was conducted
to try to understand what
factors might have influenced
the implementation
challenges that we faced.
And what we came up with was a model,
this is a very simplified version of it,
the full versions in the the
paper that you probably aren't
able to read,
but I'm happy to share the
the slides with you after.
We came up with a model that
identified kind of multi-layer
determinants that probably
looks very similar to the social
ecological model for many of
you that influenced the ability
to integrate our GBV and our
mental health components of
this intervention.
So just to go through these quickly,
at the structural level,
I mentioned at the very
beginning some of these complex
policies related to freedom of movement,
ability to kind of earn a
living and participate in
livelihood activities and
this policy landscape and the
broader context I think really
made it complex for us to
address these related issues
because in many ways those
structural factors really
reinforced some of the risks for
both GBV and mental health problems.
We also found,
and related to your earlier
question that in the legal
system there were few protections
against GBV and access
to justice was quite limited.
There was a a legal officer who
had come into the camp a few
times a week to work with people on cases,
but it was really expensive.
It took a long time.
There were a lot of factors
that made it hard for people to
access that type of support if
they they wanted to and felt
it was acceptable to do so.
Also, mental health
services were just limited.
It was not prioritized in the camp.
There weren't a lot of resources available
to address mental health needs.
And I think a lot of this was
ultimately really aggravated
by the funding environment.
So funding for GBV and mental
health are very separate and
this made it quite challenging
for us to actually convince
people funded from the mental
health actors and those funded
by the GBV funders to work
together and to try to achieve
kind of shared or respective goals.
Not to mention that a lot of
the funding requests were not
fulfilled. So while GBV was prioritized,
the funding was I think only
40% or the appeal was only 40%
percent funded and expenditures
were half of what they
actually expected.
So really under-resourced as
far as the projected needs.
Another challenge at
the next level was just
interinstitutional coordination.
And I think this is a huge
challenge in the humanitarian
sector in general, just
coordination across the board.
But surprisingly,
even between MHPSS and GBD
actors coordination was
very limited.
We found that there were
working groups operating in
the MHPSS space and the GBD
space who would say we know the
importance of the other,
we know that this is
related to what we're doing,
but there was very little actual
talking or no joint action
plans about how these two sectors
of two areas would work together.
We also found, found
that within the GBV plan,
it included an element
of psychosocial support,
but not really any
operationalization of what that was.
It was just this mandate or
this recommendation I should
say, to provide psychosocial
support but with very little
guidance on how to do that.
And similarly, within
the MHPSS working group,
which was designed to be
multi-sectorial or cross-sectoral,
the actors involved were largely
working within the health
system as opposed to engaging
with the protection sector.
I don't know how to solve this one,
but if people have ideas,
I'd love love to hear them.
So at the next level,
we have the inter-institutional context.
And this is where I think we
most acutely saw some of our
challenges within the
organization we were working with.
There was a really high rate
of staff turnover at all levels
from headquarters down
to the field staff level.
And this made it challenging
for us to have kind of reliable
engagement and buy-in from
our partners because it varied
based on whoever was the
decision maker at that point.
And I think ultimately made
it really difficult for our
counselors to know who they
were accountable to or what they
were accountable to.
Another challenge is, I mentioned earlier,
is that given the siloed
funding and the project-based
funding that exists in
the humanitarian sector,
a lot of or the recognition
that it made sense to integrate
mental health and GBV was
often kind of overcome by the
need to be accountable to
whatever the objectives were of a,
of a donor funded program.
And so there was just a lot
of competing priorities and
challenges in terms of adopting
and being more flexible
about this intersectorial approach.
And then finally, at the
community level, I think
the main takeaway for me is
that women who participated and
the community more broadly
really recognized the value of
bringing this intervention
together that addressed what they
referred to as their home environment,
their interpersonal relationships
as well as their minds or
their mental health.
But there was this broad
agreement that it was really
insufficient to actually address
the root causes of violence.
And many recommendations came up around
providing services to men, engaging,
incorporating livelihood opportunities
and other factors as well.
So some of my key takeaways
from this project,
which is a really formative
learning experience for me was
just the importance of
prioritizing a prevention approach,
making sure that we're
incorporating considerations for the
social and contextual
determinants of mental health
and of GBV and also making sure
that we are from the outset
promoting engagement and ownership.
I think that is so central
to kind of success in any of
these more complicated types
of interventions and projects.
So just before I wrap up,
I wanted to highlight a,
just a couple of ongoing
projects that are hopefully
building on some of our lessons learned
from the Nguvu program.
So over the past three or four
years I've been working with
HIAs, a humanitarian organization
that is focused on refugee
protection. They provide, they
have kind of four pillars.
They provide legal assistance,
they do social protection,
which includes GBV
prevention and response,
economic inclusion,
and also mental health
and psychosocial support.
And over the past few years
we've been working on some
projects primarily focused
on providing services for
Venezuelan migrants.
As many probably in the room
know the economic and political
crisis in Venezuela has led
to over 7 million Venezuelans
fleeing the country and
over 6 million of those have
remained in Latin America.
And as you can see here a lot
within Columbia and Peru and
in Ecuador.
So our work with HIAs has been
to work along key migration
route and to evaluate the
effectiveness and implementation
of community-based
psychosocial and mental health
interventions that
integrate MHPSS with social
protection and economic
support for refugees, migrants,
and also host communities
in these various sites in Latin America.
This goes back to this
integrated intervention model and
just recognizing and here
are some of the common things
we've heard about in our
formative research around
the drivers of mental health
problems and what those salient
mental health problems are.
But we need to think about
these mental health conditions
within the context of safety
and security discrimination and
xenophobia, social connectedness,
social networks and GBV.
I also wanted to highlight
a few of the mental health
conditions or constructs that came up
in a lot of our interviews.
The first one, malaestar emocional is not
I think a very direct translation,
but it's the concept of kind
of a poor state of emotional
being which came up repeatedly
in a lot of our different interviews.
Similarly, sadness has
come up quite a bit,
as has this other construct
of duelo migratorio
which is the concept around
migratory grief and mourning.
And I think these are really
interesting because again,
a lot of our mental health
interventions are not really
designed to focus on migration related
grief and are much more, I guess,
optimized to address some of
the more clinical mental health
conditions we're more familiar with.
So all of these projects
started off during covid
and so that of course
added another layer to,
and really exacerbated a lot
of these risk factors for
mental health problems
and caused unique forms
of distress as well.
Here are just some quotes
from some of the qualitative
interviews we've done with
migrants in Latin America that I
think really speak to the
connection between mental health
challenges and the pandemic.
The first quote is from a mother
who talks about her fear of
actually catching covid and
what will happen if she herself
becomes sick and dies,
who will ultimately take
care of her children.
The middle quote I think is
really interesting because one
of the things we found is a lot of
the supports people have received,
Venezuelan migrants have received
in Latin America has been
through community networks
and host communities providing
informal supports to
migrants who are arriving.
But as this person says,
during the pandemic,
everyone was really stressed
and worried and people were no
longer as willing to help because
of the fear that they
had of catching covid.
And then the final quote
relates more to this issue of
livelihoods and work opportunities.
This comes from a woman in Panama
who talks about how before or now during
the pandemic you can't really
move before you could at least
clean people's houses and now
people are nervous to bring
strangers into their home.
And so they've now lost another source
of livelihoods there as well.
So one study I wanted just to
highlight is we conducted in
Panama and in Ecuador where
really the goal here was to
start off at the very outset
of engaging with communities to
design mental health and
psychosocial intervention combined
with a social protection
element to meet the needs of
refugee migrant and host
community women in three really
diverse sites in Latin America.
And we intentionally selected
these three different sites in
order to understand what is
the role of context as we think
about implementation and the design
of mental health interventions.
The first site in is in Panama,
so Panama City as well as three
communities that are kind of
peri-urban communities around
Panama City that where a lot
of migrants have have moved.
We also worked in Tulcan, Ecuador,
which is on the border with Columbia.
It's a pretty remote rural
town and often a transit point
for migrants who are moving further south.
And we also worked in Guayaquil, Ecuador,
which is a large city,
very urban setting and a
destination for many migrants in
Ecuador or migrants from Venezuela.
And as part of this process
we went through a an initial
participatory intervention design process.
So we started with the similar
formative research that I
described in the previous study
where we identified what are
the most salient outcomes
affecting migrant women in these
settings and those four
are listed on your right.
And then we asked people,
what type of intervention
would you like to see
to address these problems?
And pretty consistently what
we heard is that women wanted a
safe space to come together
as a group to address their needs.
And the fun part of all of this is kind of
what happened in the middle.
And so we said, okay,
so we have this group
intervention that we want to
ultimately improve mental
health, improve safety,
improve connectedness and social support.
How would an intervention
like this do that?
And through this really iterative
and kind of community led process,
we articulated five key
mechanisms that community members
felt like would lead to these outcomes.
And those are the five
mechanisms listed here.
And then the final step of
this process was to say, okay,
you want to enhance safety and protection.
How would you do that?
What are some activities or
intervention components that we
can bring into this intervention
in order to activate that mechanism?
And the part of this though was
so interesting as we brought
in components from
evidence-based interventions,
existing interventions and
kind of hopped those with
participants but also had
women bring in kind of local
practices and processes that
they had used or they were
familiar with in their cultural
context in order to activate
these mechanisms and
ultimately kind of combined and
massaged and iterated of those
in order to ultimately arrive
at the Entre Nosotras intervention.
Entre Nosotras means among
or between us in Spanish,
it is a strength-based
intervention that is a five session
weekly intervention that covers
the five topics listed on this slide.
It is delivered by a trained,
a pair of trained facilitators.
So community members,
many of whom were actually
involved in the intervention
design itself to groups of
women in their communities.
This was much more of a mental
health promotion and kind of
protection intervention than
it was more of a clinical one.
And so we focused this
intervention on women in the
community who had kind
of low to moderate levels
of distress as well.
And we also ensured that this
intervention was adaptable
across each of our study contexts.
So in this study,
ultimately 225 women
participated in the intervention.
About two-thirds of them were Venezuelan,
they were 36 years old on average,
about half of them were unemployed.
And among those who were employed,
most of that was informal labor,
so really unstable kind
of work situations.
And a quarter of those had
arrived within the past year and
then another half I think had
arrived within the past three years.
So we looked at their kind
of wellbeing outcomes,
a set of selected outcomes that
mapped on to those priority outcomes
we identified through that
formative research process and
examined changes from
baseline to end line,
which was about five weeks
and then 10 weeks later.
And ultimately what we found
were moderate improvements in
the positive mental health outcomes.
We saw improvements in
psychosocial wellbeing,
community connectedness
and sense of safety.
But again, we observed this pattern
where people initially get better
and then after the intervention
ends they kind of return
toward where they started,
which is something we need
to to figure out as a field.
I think what we didn't see any
significant changes in were
more of those problem focused
outcomes and these are the
outcomes that we often measure
in mental health research.
Things like distress functioning, coping.
But what I think was really
interesting here was that the
groups that we saw the greatest
improvement in were those
women who were employed, women
who started off a bit worse,
so had higher distress or lower wellbeing,
which makes sense.
And also women who attended more sessions.
The reason I say this is
interesting is I think the
employment piece comes
out in two ways here.
First, we saw that women
who were employed who had more economic
stability responded better
to the intervention,
they improved at a greater rate.
We also saw that jobs were a
barrier to participation in the
women when they were choosing
between whether to to work
that day or come to the intervention.
Of course they would choose work.
And so this made this complicated
situation where we thought
the women who could benefit
the most actually had the least
access or ability to participate.
And so this has led us to
a project that's just now
beginning where we are now
still working in Ecuador with
HIAs to co-design implementation
strategies to think about
how we integrate an
MHPSS intervention like
the one I just shared within
their economic services.
And we're doing that through
integrating their MHPSS
services with an intervention
known as the socioeconomic
support program for those who
might be familiar with
the graduation model.
It's kind of an abbreviated
version of that that starts by
identifying and engaging families,
migrant families who
are in extreme poverty,
providing some basic
con consumption support,
so cash or vouchers for
food and things like that.
And then providing training
and how to save money,
financial literacy skills for
employment and families enter
into what's called an employment
or entrepreneurship school
that provides them with the
support and skills to ultimately
start a business or get a job.
And we're currently in this
process of like mapping all of
the details of this very
complicated intervention and trying
to think about how and where
to integrate those MHPSS supports.
All right, the last
thing I'll just end with
is one more project that
actually ends on Friday.
So these analyses are literally
just being done as we speak,
but this is a project again
with HIAs in Columbia where
now we're trying to understand
what are the relative effects
of different integration,
multi-sectoral integration
approaches as far as
implementation and effectiveness outcomes.
So here we're working with
a scalable intervention developed
by the World Health Organization
known as Problem
Management plus or PM plus
in its group format.
And this is an intervention
that's had a large growing evidence base.
It's based on cognitive behavioral
therapy and a lot of some
of the common kind of problem
solving skills that are
central to a lot of mental
health interventions.
And what we're testing, like I said,
are two models of how to
integrate this intervention within
protection services,
community-based protection services.
We're working in three
communities in the area of in
Northern Columbia where a
lot of migrants have settled.
And the first condition we're
comparing is what I'll refer
to as the traditional task sharing model.
And so in this model we have
a psychologist or a mental
health specialist who trains
and supervises a group of,
we'll say non-specialists,
people without formal
mental health training
to deliver this intervention.
And the people we've decided to train
are similar to the Nguvu program.
They're community women from
the community who are working
with HIAs and serving as
kind of social promoters
of protection services.
They kind of serve as a liaison between
HIAs and the community,
do community outreach and
provide kind of some basic
services and supports
at the community level.
And so in our first phase of this project,
we trained a group of I think
six to eight social worker
community promoters to provide
this intervention to groups
of women in their community.
And I'll consider this kind
of a partial integration model
because it still has some
reliance on that mental health
specialist to provide that
training and supervision.
So in many ways it's still expensive.
It still might not be as scalable because
it still requires the time, energy,
and salary of a full-time psychologist
in order to implement this model.
The second condition for the
study is what we call the
cascading cash sharing model.
And so here we're further
decentralizing a lot of the roles
and activities of the
psychologists to community members.
And this is what we're also
calling more full integration of
MHPSS into the community-based
protection system.
So in this model, what we found is,
or what we did is we had a
psychologist train a group of the
women we had trained in the
initial phase to actually be
trainers and supervisors themselves.
And then those community
promoters trained a new group of
women who are community
promoters to provide the
intervention to other women in
their community and served as
kind of trainers and supervisors
throughout that whole process.
And so while the psychologist
is still a piece of this,
they're not requiring or not
providing that regular weekly
supervision and support but
rather on more of a kind
of consultative basis.
So what we found, and
again these are very,
very preliminary results.
So we did observe just between
people who received the
intervention and those who did not.
We did observe an
additional, or excuse me,
an initial a reduction in
depressive symptoms during the
intervention period.
But again, we still see
that kind of regression
back toward baseline,
which is something that is important
for us to to grapple with.
But what I think is the really
exciting finding here is when
we compare those two
implementation strategies,
those two models of integration,
we actually see very similar
patterns as far as depression
outcomes where the trajectories
of depression among people
who received the intervention
from from community promoters
trained by specialists was
very similar to people who
received the intervention from
community promoters who were
trained and supervised by
other community promoters.
So that fully integrated
community-based protection model.
Our preliminary results also
suggest that we see comparable
fidelity and competencies among
our providers between these
two study conditions, which
I think is quite promising.
So just as far as conclusions,
I think there's still a lot to learn,
but I think what we have slowly
been learning along the way
is that integrating MHPSS
into other sectors like
protection like livelihoods
seems to be quite relevant to
the needs of these communities.
We also can see that
it's feasible to do that.
While there are all of these
challenges I shared with
funding and organizational mandates
and all of these other factors,
it does appear that it is
feasible for us to design and
integrate these services as
long as we meaningfully engage
and kind of co-design these
approaches with people,
representatives from other sectors.
And we have some preliminary
evidence that the quality and
effectiveness of the these
mental health interventions can
be maintained when we integrate
them within other sectors
and that we don't kind of
dilute the mental health effects
by transitioning them into
other sectors and spaces and systems.
There's still a lot we need to
know like how do we actually
sustain the benefits
of these interventions?
How do we reconceptualize these
interventions so they might
not be kind of an insular process,
but we can provide some
ongoing support to people to
maintain those benefits.
How do we think about the
kind of structural and
interinstitutional determinants
which we haven't really
captured here?
There's a lot we still need to
know and a lot of questions,
which is why I would like to
end by saying thank you so much
for your time and I'd love
to hear your thoughts and
questions going forward.
I will just say also
big thanks to our teams.
These are some photos from our
different research teams on
these projects and for me,
by far the best part of this
work is building relationships
and the the collaboration.
So I can't thank these
people enough. Thank you.
(clapping)
- We have a question on zoom from Melody.
So she was asking if you know,
what is the reason
or if you can speculate
why in the Nyarugusu study
you would see such a high staff turnover?
- That is a good question.
So I think we saw high staff
turnover at multiple levels.
I actually, so as far
as the staff, I kind of,
the people most involved in implementation
were our facilitators,
the counselors we trained.
The main cause of turnover
there was actually resettlement, which is
a good reason for turnover to happen.
There was active resettlement happening
in the beginning stages of the project.
That was actually the largest
reason that participants
dropped out of the program as well.
But at slightly higher
levels and Kaveh and I
were talking about this earlier,
I think it is really hard to
do this work and I think in a
place like Nyarugusu a really
protracted complex context,
a lot of the staff kind of the field staff
are really burnt out.
And so we saw a lot of turnover,
people moving between sites.
That was quite common.
Unfortunately we also saw
that at the higher levels.
One of our initial partners
on the project had another job
opportunity and so ultimately
left the organization and that
I think happened less
frequently, but it was pretty,
it had a pretty big impact on
our program cause I think she
was really the champion of
this approach within her
organization at the headquarters level.
So I think there are a lot
of reasons for turnover,
but I think it's really hard work
and common to see these levels of turnover
at the field staff level.
- Can I ask a question?
- Yes.
- I just had a question similarly about
the Nguvu intervention and that in the end
that you found that it
was better to organize,
to not organize outcomes or
depressive symptoms or these
symptoms via you know, PTSD
dep depression anxiety,
but rather hofu huzuni and the third,
I just don't wanna butcher that one.
I'm wondering moving forward, how do you,
if you wanted to examine any
other kind of conditions in
relation to mental health,
like would you use that
as the reference and then
essentially how do you use that
moving forward as your measurement?
- I know because it's probably
going to going to change not
only across different populations
but also over time too.
You know, it's a really good question.
We grapple,
there's a paper we published on this
and I'm glad you're asking about this.
We, surprisingly, it's one of the things
I'm still fascinated by was that that
finding or that kind of
triangulation of information.
One of the ways that we've
thought about this in our group
is I think there is still
value in using measures across
multiple contexts for comparison's sake.
But I think we need to
be more deliberate about
incorporating items that reflect
local concepts of distress.
So there's been some work by
Emily Harris and others who
have like looked mapped all of
like the depression measures
across the world and how
they've been used and identified
some unique items across
different contexts.
And so one of the strategies
they suggest is try to find
like a core set of items
that you think are helpful to
measure across multiple
studies and across populations.
But through this formative
research process,
identify some items that are
missing that you can then kind
of integrate into your measures.
I don't know that I would recommend,
unless I was working in
the very same context and could have,
could validate that these
three concepts of distress
were still appropriate.
I wouldn't necessarily
take those three idioms
and apply them in different places, right?
Because I don't think they're universal
or even kind of static.
I think they, these things are
fluid and and quite dynamic.
So we have to kind of think
more flexibly about how we
design our measures to enable
kind of both of those comparisons.
Does that answer your question?
- Yeah, I have a very small follow up.
I'm sorry.
This is like very applicable
to my work in that.
You might find for instance,
that somebody else has used PCL five or
the trial questionnaire in that country.
But essentially what
you're arguing is like,
yeah I might work at this level,
but if you really wanna get
a more accurate estimate,
it's incorporating kind of
that variation that's based off
cultural or you know, the local context
interpretation of these conditions.
- Totally yeah and I think,
I mean one of the things that's hard too
is like when we looked at the,
before we did that exploratory
factor analysis and just
allowed the items to
correlate as they may,
if you did look at things
like internal consistency
and the kind of confirmatory
factor analysis,
like how well did the data fit depression,
anxiety and PTSD and there
were no like major red flags,
but it did seem that after
doing this EFA approach that
actually the data fit the
concepts we heard about in the
formative research much better
or more naturally perhaps.
And so I think even if something has been
validated elsewhere,
I think it's always still good
for you to kind of explore
what is missing and how can we think about
balancing those two approaches.
- I have two questions related to
the communities response to
these mental health interventions.
The first one is,
I guess on how the people perceive
these interventions to be affected or not.
And especially coming in
I guess as people from
the northern or more developed countries,
are there any instances or
risk of cultural appropriation
of what mental health issues were
in the local context?
Especially in, I guess among some of
the refugee community units,
patriarchy might be a lot
more of an issue and certain
practices they have is not,
is quite foreign to us.
So I think that's the first
question on how you are able to
navigate that while trying to measure
mental health conditions.
And the second one is on,
I guess once interventions end,
what is that transition
process like and how is the
community able to, I guess,
move forward with it or
continue to benefit from it
even if programs end.
- I love both of these questions,
so taking the first one,
I mean I think the question
around like how communities
respond I think is one that
is I've evolved or thought
differently about over time
and it's really kind of what
I've used as kind of my guide
in thinking about future
projects and steps.
I mean I think it ultimately
comes down to where who's
making, who has the decision
making power and in what the
intervention looks like and
how it's tested and evaluated.
I think one of,
with the example I gave from
Ecuador and Panama where we
kind of said like, okay the design,
the intervention based on what
fits will offer some ideas.
But the community really did design that.
I think there are a lot of
people who are very skeptical
about that approach because
there is this interesting debate
I think in the field
right now between like the
holding kind of true or kind
of maintaining the fidelity to
what we have evidence for and
relaxing that toward more of a
kind of cultural relativistic approach.
And I have swung a little
bit more in that direction
recently and and think that we
have kind of the potential to
do less harm by transitioning
some of that decision making
power to the community themselves.
And I think the,
like is this that
intervention as effective
as something else? I'm not sure.
One of the things that I didn't
actually mention here is I'm
part of that study design.
We integrated one external
component and did kind of a
comparative effectiveness
trial comparing two versions of
the intervention.
One that was enhanced with
this WHO intervention and one
was that was the community
design version alone.
And we actually found there
was only one indication that
there was, were any differences in their,
in how people responded to them
or people's trajectories as
far as their outcomes.
So I think this is a big
debate at the moment,
but I guess I am leaning toward
if you enable and facilitate
the decision making power to
happen within communities,
I think, I think you run less of a risk
of some of the points that
you brought up.
But it is, yeah,
there's a lot of debate on that topic.
Your question around
sustainability is also
a really good one.
So the very, the final
project that I mentioned,
the one in Columbia where we
kind of trained these different
groups of providers and
counselors and trainers and
supervisors, the feedback
we got at the very end.
So we did, we had some focus groups
with our counselors and our
trainers and supervisors to say like,
to get their feedback but
also to go through this
sustainability planning
process, excuse me,
where we actually asked them like,
what would you need to sustain
this program? Is it money?
Is it space? What?
Like what would that look
like to you and how would you
design this going forward?
And it was interesting and
we're actually thinking of
talking with the donor
about this for an next,
the next stage or the next
version iteration of that project
where what the community wanted
was some kind of formalized
process of seeing themselves
as a community-based organization.
And so, which I thought
was really interesting
because in some ways
providing the skills and the
infrastructure for them to
organize and be seen as kind
of this entity within the
community that has this set of
skills and that they can then
kind of leverage in different
ways with the government or
with different organizations,
I think is really powerful.
And so that's actually what
we're thinking at this stage is
how can we better facilitate
that organization and
mobilization of these women
into groups that can then kind
of sustain the project in the longer term.
But I think there are not
a lot of good examples
of sustainment of these types
of interventions for the
reasons you're probably alluding to.
- There is one additional,
a couple of additional questions here.
Abre, do you want to ask the questions?
Well, otherwise I just read,
so she says that if you would
share some details of how
about how GPM plus participants
were selected and how groups
were formed and it,
did women know each other and
if they knew or did not each
other, do you think if it influenced
the impact on the intervention?
- Good question. And yes, I
rushed through that example,
so didn't go through
those details. So the,
for the last study with
the group PM plus model,
there were selection criteria
to identify women who were
experiencing some level
moderate level of distress and
functional impairment as well.
The women identified actually
came through two sources.
One was people,
women who had sought support
through HIAs and then HIAs
referred them to the program.
The other was through the facilitators
or the counselors themselves.
So them kind of referring women to HIAs
so that they could participate.
And so it was kind of two
pronged as far as through the
humanitarian organization as
well as through the community.
The second part of that question
was, oh, about how women,
the groups were formed.
So the groups were formed
within those three communities.
They were kind of far
apart from each other.
And so it is likely that women
knew each other or some women
might have known each other beforehand.
I don't think that was
the case all the time.
We're still analyzing
our qualitative data,
which is where we would be
able to answer that more
directly. So I can't say for sure,
but what I will say is actually
from the Nguvu intervention
initially we had assumed that
it was better to keep groups separate,
not to have kind of friends or
people who knew each other in
the same groups, especially
when talking about IPV.
And what we found, I
guess was the opposite,
that women actually wanted
to kind of maintain their
existing networks when
they participated in the intervention.
The exception being is if
there were was some sort of
generational difference.
So women did not want to be younger,
women did not wanna be in the
same group as an older woman
for kind of cultural reasons.
And so we had to stratify
the groups by age,
but also it was actually
preferred for women from the same
women's groups to participate
in groups together.
That answers the question.
- Okay. And there is
another question from Lami.
So first she thank you
for the great work and
presentation and then she
said if you can get some the
thought as the best practices
and your recommendation as to
how to evaluate the added
value of multi sexual
interventions that integrates
mental health with other
services included cash transfer
in human humanitarian settings.
- Yeah, that's also a
really good question.
So based with my collaborators at HIAs,
they actually just formed a working group
then through the IASC,
the interagency standing
committee on MHPSS
MHPSS cash and livelihoods.
So I think there's a lot of
energy and focus on kind of
understanding how to integrate.
But as far as how to evaluate,
I think the next big step is
thinking about is mapping and
evaluating outcomes,
both economic and mental
health outcomes and determining
whether that integration
actually improves those outcomes
synergistically more than
we would see if they were
operating independently.
It's a big project,
I think that's hoping where we
hope to go with this project
in Ecuador, but I think
that's a ways down the line.
The second part of that question
in addition to evaluating was subject.
- Yeah, basically, yeah,
integrating with the cash
transfers in humanitarian setting.
- This is Dr. Joma Leense,
the one who just asked the
question about the integration.
Dr. Greene, I really
appreciate your thoughts
and the reason I was
asking about the
recommendations, 'cause you said
it can be rather messy to
work with the integration of
services and sometimes
just getting the buy-in.
And the reason why I'm asking
that is because we're trying
to do this work in Lebanon
with Syrian refugees
and Lebanese host communities.
And one of the major challenges
is sometimes you have
a combination of things going on.
We have some services that are
already integrated and nobody
is doing any evaluation and
it's kind of some form of
integration and then some that
are looking at it and kind of
thinking why they added, you know,
challenges and barriers and
let alone also the identity of
the refugees that take the cash
transfers that may not want
to be known for the mental
health and vice versa.
So I guess the question was
really multi folded is one,
how do you overcome those challenges
to get the buy-in for
those different services,
to talk to each other and to do that.
And when it comes to evaluation,
and maybe this is a conversation
beyond today, but I just,
yeah, I wanted those thoughts about the
kind of behind the curtain.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I'd love to talk more,
so please, please reach out.
I think it's, as you're saying this,
I mean it's funny because I,
one of the challenges
that we've had in our,
our early attempts to do this
is to actually get even within
the same organization,
the economics team and the MHPSS team
to speak the same language.
And it's, I think ultimately
what I've arrived at is,
I think a big takeaway for
me is ensuring that at every
stage in these projects,
making sure there's kind of
equal representation across
sectors from the design,
through the implementation,
through the evaluation,
so that you kind of are
aligned throughout the entire
process. But as you're
talking about evaluation,
it reminds me one of the things
that we've come up against
is even just the way
we operationalize some
of the key outcomes.
So for example, the economics team,
one of their main outcomes of this
intervention is community integration,
promoting community integration
through this economics and
livelihoods intervention.
And so we've been trying to
figure out between the MHPSS
team and the economics team,
how do we measure that?
And what we've discovered is
actually our kind of the root
of what we think community integration is,
is totally different.
And this comes down to a conversation
we had even about social support,
where the economics team has really been
focused around instrumental support.
How many people do you have in
your network who can provide
a loan if you need, if you
need cash for something.
Versus the more traditional
mental health intervention is
like how many people do you
have to talk to or support you
when you're having trouble with something.
And so I think even just
aligning the way what we're
evaluating as far as our
outcomes across sectors
can be quite challenging.
The other thing that we've
kind of come up against that
might be less complex with
cash than some of the other
interventions is just the
complexity of mental health
interventions and the
economics interventions make it
really, I think, hard for us
to isolate impacts, right?
And also when we're thinking about,
to your point around participation,
all of the people participating
in an economics intervention
might not be appropriate for
the same type of type of mental
health intervention.
And so how do we think about, like,
what are we really evaluating then?
So I think it's quite complicated
and something we haven't
fully navigated ourselves yet,
but I'd love to to chat more
as you're grappling with this as well.
Thanks for the question.
- There is a question by
Charles, do you want to ask?
- Yeah, sure.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you Professor Greene.
I think this is really super
important work and it's right
on the cutting edge of mental
health and psycho psychosocial
support and localization.
And I'm a sociologist and
I've been nine months into 12
months of ethnographic work
asking mental health workers
about how they're localizing
their work and the struggles
that they face as they're
working with refugees in spaces.
And I think what you're
saying about like having these
initial assessments about the
drivers of mental health and
how they should be culturally
situated is super awesome and
I think it's becoming
more common, but the,
the examples that you gave in
Panama and Ecuador where the
actual interventions are culturally based,
I think that's still something
that there's a lot of space
to be, a lot of growth.
I know like bra IRC and a lot
of other organizations are
all kind of using the same interventions.
So when I talk to these kind
of small and medium sized
organizations and the people
who are working within them,
they have a lot of struggle
because these workers are really
dedicated to supporting refugees.
But then when they're trying
to localize the work, it's,
they don't know what to do
with their expertise, right?
So their,
their mental health and
psychosocial support exports, right?
But if the intervention should
be locally based and ones
that are determined by
the target community,
they don't know they, are they
just creating space, right?
Or do they actually have an
expertise that they're bringing
to the table but then they can, you know,
talk about with the refugee community.
So I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about how
people who are struggling
with the localization of these
programs who wanna do such good work,
how do you see the line of like
where your expertise comes in,
whether it's just a political
project of creating space for
people alongside giving
the living support,
things like that.
So it seems like a
complicated normative space.
I was just wondering if
you thought about that and,
and any advice you could
give these experts.
- Oh, advice, yeah,
that's a good question and
thanks for those thoughts.
I mean I, yeah, I mean
our, so our partners,
I guess my closest partners
in both Ecuador and Panama are
themselves psychologists,
but they come from a world
of community psychology,
which is a discipline that I'm
not as familiar with here in
the us but I think is something
that is much more robust
in Latin America, for example.
And I think more amenable
to some of these,
I guess more collaborative
approaches to designing and
thinking about mental
health interventions.
I mean I what I guess the
discomfort with deviating from
kind of what is evidence-based
or what we think is
evidence-based.
For me, I think the role
maybe of the specialist is to,
is first to just of making
sure that the interventions
themselves are safe and
we're not kind of creating a
situation that could lead to harm.
I think that is kind of
paramount and kind of a good
starting point for their
role and something that these
people have the expertise
to do and the knowledge,
I mean I think a lot of it,
and this is a challenge that
I've been talking a lot with
HIAs about is like these
formative phases take a year and
it's a lot of building
relationships and a lot of building
trust and sometimes to humanitarian
organizations don't have
that luxury of taking a year
to go through this process.
But I think the benefit and
where we got was a really nice
place where it was an exchange
between the community and the
psychologists and the, our team
that felt really horizontal.
I think it felt really like
they were collaboratively
working toward an intervention
together as opposed to taking
something and tweaking
it to fit here and there,
which I think is what happens
in a lot of adaptations.
But I think it takes time.
And so I don't know what the
solution is in a context where
you don't have that luxury.
I think that is, that is tricky.
And I, yeah,
I don't know if I have an
answer to toward you on that,
but I think that there still
is a very valuable role
of specialists and kind of being
facilitators and guides and
providing, being part of the,
having a seat at the table but
not necessarily driving it.
Hope that answered.
- Yeah, that's great.
Thank you.
- Yeah, happy to talk more too.
- Professor Claire Greene,
thank you so much for great
talk and was a great question.
(clapping)